it just shows how actually emotions are
stronger than reason cuz you look at all
these people or a lot of these people
who are afflicted by whatever you want
to call it mind virus ideology they're
all very intelligent they all went to
the best university it's easier to train
a smart dog than a dumb one you have to
have a certain amount of intellectual
heft to engage in the mental gymnastics
to keep a ridiculous philosophy in your
mind and it also is a point of Pride was
a tertullian uh you know I believe
because it's absurd it makes you feel
it's kind of uh any kind of mystery
religion where you initiated into the
faith and you understand things that the
normes regard is absurd you know that is
something that is a point of Pride not a
point of
Shame